well after nearly a year of distance
learning the clark county school
district
is now working to get students and
teachers back in the classroom
as k huston houston reports parents are
basically split on whether or not
this is the best decision for their kids
sylvia federico has six children in the
clark county school district from pre-k
to high school
i feel that they need to be in school
federico is in support of the board of
trustees decision to eventually move
kindergarten through third grade into a
hybrid model principals will also be
able to bring
small groups of students who need extra
support onto separate campuses on a
voluntary basis
i appreciate that they're that they are
considering
the children's needs they did still
leave that choice
so if somebody wants to stay home or if
their family feels hey i'm going to stay
home this year
you can still stay home on friday ccsd
superintendent dr jesus jarrah
said while there is no set timeline if
planning goes smoothly there could be
groups back on campus by late february
or early march but not all parents are
convinced
it's so big that i feel like that
it's passing the buck katie busser has
four kids in the school district
she's concerned the approved plan leaves
more questions than
answers we are already made way through
january
we only have a few months left what they
really like the ccsc to focus on
is next school year and how to make that
make that transition then to back to
in-person learning and how to make that
work
dr jara says data from ccea shows a
majority of teachers want to be back in
class with students
in order for that to happen principals
will need to submit their plan to a
regional superintendent for approval
despite concerns about a lack of
transportation for students in the
voluntary model
dr jara says they're working to ensure
there's equity for students across the
district
keith houston 8 news now